je verrai comment c'était pire parce que
j'avais un avis je me disais ça se
trouve à la paf exprès ça se trouve on
sait pas ce qu'on valait vraiment hors
dehors dehors des choses et quand elle
va pas quand elle a commencé à parler
sur 66 minutes jeu plus l'interview
avance puis je me dis mais quelle petite
menteuse c'est une petite menteuse de a
à z a dit qu'il ne maîtrise pas les
réseaux a dit moi j'y connais rien les
réseaux tindle j'y connais rien je ne
savais pas d'autres gens envoyer des
photos par mois sauf que quand un
canthare soit les photos elle fait des
captures d'écran donc si tu fais des
câbles personnes fêtaient la dictée pour
se protéger alors personne fait des
captures d'écran sans arrière pensée je
vous le dis quand tu reçu une photo si
elle cite après un accord entre deux
adultes et qui puisait vous faites de
l'adultère si tu sais que tu reçois une
capture d'écran de ce mec là si vous
êtes mis d'accord tous les deux pour que
ça dure une minute ça dure une minute et
poubelles t'as pas besoin de la garder
elle dit qu'elle maîtrise pas les
réseaux après dis je c'est un homme
politique on voulait pas qu'ils se
rencontrent dans un lieu public il avait
dit pas de public je l'emmène chez moi
elle n'a jamais vu le connais pas fait
venir des hommes chez elle lassé barros
a apprécié en vous un mini miss tout le
temps de trucs à dire violent contre
vous faites vous en faites bien des
histoires pour des photos pornos il en
arrive tous les jours
moi j'ai pas tous les jours un ministre
qui se met à poil chez moi
[Applaudissements]
il nous raconte de la mère m'a dit
qu'ils maîtrisent pas les réseaux etc
etc
elle sort avec un gars qui est à l'asile
politique
ethier l'autre c'est dans la politique
piotr tu sors avec lui tulle m
premier réflexe j'étais avec griveaux je
sais que j'ai fait des conneries avec
griveaux j'ai c'est que de fait que
l'adultère piotr je laime je vire tout
de suite ces photos ça ça va l'emmener
en prison quand il va trouver ça dans
mon portable il va s'en servir
parce que c'est un homme politique ne
fait pas ls 10 laisse les photos et
quand on lui pose la question c'est vous
qui l'avez montré les photos et je ne
sais pas demandez lui entame sa
crédibilité et toute sa crédibilité
vous savez moi j'ai des principes et
j'ai une morale avant et tu fais venir
un mec marié chez toi avec des enfants
ils étaient ôtés principe est amoral
quand il est venu là on appelle avec le
sait marier les prayssas avait bien ri a
fait qu'on lui l'a fait coup je m'en
fous de grimaud il a fait le con c'est
pas mon problème grévaux mais ce qu'elle
a dit elle en disant j'ai des principes
tu as des principes tu fais venir un
homme marié chez toi moi je suis
persuadée qu'elle était déjà avec 4
pavés des pièces qui après le pilote et
après lui dit il a ses idées politiques
moi je suis là pour combattre après
bascule dans un discours politique parce
qu'elle dit il a ses idées il joue le
bon père de famille et alors tu as une
rodez une relation adultère avec lui tu
fais tes trucs avec lui c'est tout ou à
mon avis tu voulais rester avec griveaux
est à jeter état d'ivresse avec madame
et puis tu t'es venger d'arrière gauche
alors tu peux manger plein de trucs
enquête amorcée l'interview de la
menteuse tu es une menteuse
alors regardez alors elle donne sa
version des faits sur le fait que son
compagnon madeleine ce qu'ils aient pu
avoir accès à ces vidéos comme vous
dites selon elle elle y en a jamais
parlé regardez bien sûr voulu parler
également de l'existence de ces vidéos
que vous avez enregistré jeu 12 en avoir
parlé comment ils le découvrent il faut
lui demander c'est pas vous qui lui avez
non je vais pas montrer ses visées je
pense que honnêtement j'avais un peu
oublié l'existence de ces vidéos
c'était là ça va bientôt faire deux ans
que mes ou un an et demi ça va bientôt
faire un an et demi que ces vidéos ont
été captées plus ou moins j'ai oublié
beaucoup de choses qui sont dans mon
ordinateur depuis un an et demi elle a
oublié le très drôle à l'oublier ça
arrive d'oublier
tu fais jamais tu vas pas sur les
réseaux sociaux il le dit je connais pas
c'est mes amis vont cette charte indoor
alors j'ai appris comme ça qu'on pouvait
envoyer des photos qui a bizarrement il
ya un ministre de la france sait pas
c'est pas un charcutier c'est pas c'est
pas un épicier c'est un ministre de la
france qui lui envoient des vidéos et en
18 mois
ben je vous dis moi j'avais oublié que
j'avais ces vidéos dans mon téléphone
études sup ma gueule et moi boire
hassidim a changé mon filtre rg c'est
que j'ai la vidéo de mon portable
[Applaudissements]